so
uh hello my dear friends
uh this is uh professor pradeep kumar
um a professor of the department of
biochemistry
uh jp institute of post graduate medical
institute in research in delhi
heart of india the capital
and i'm also attached with the ifcc as
in consultant as a task force consultant
for the task force
and scientists and also with the ifcc
emerging technologies division as a
member of
mhblm committee and also member of the
apfcb communication
and publication committee and also
participating as an anybody assessor for
medical laboratories
as per iso 15189
so here uh this is my slides
about my institute
that is the gyma which is a super
speciality institute
of the uh the capital
of india that is delhi under the
government of delhi
and is working for uh super specialties
like the neurology
cardiac sciences the psychiatry
and the sciences
today i'm going to discuss my slides
into the different heads
like the clinical test the way the lab
stands
the evolving cardiac biomarkers
the opportunities for improvement and
the the different
ai challenges that we are facing in the
current state
so uh when we are talking about the
clinical test
as a part of laboratory so uh of course
the patient is very important
in today's era because the patient is
you know playing a much larger role
into the decision making and it is
always into the great demands towards
the hill services of course because
the information is widely available onto
the internet
and for that reason as you can see you
know uh
because of going for more complexity of
uh
the clinical testing where we are you
know trying to shift
our strategies from the one medicine
which fits
all in every people to the precision
medicine which is a personalized
medicine so uh today's clinical lab is
becoming
one of the hospitals largest departments
and that's providing you know the vital
information for the
effective health care delivery thus
you know we are the the battery is
becoming the import
source of the diagnostic information
now when um we are talking about the
cardiology so as a part of the body i
see the chronic biomarkers refer to the
substances
which are released into the bloodstream
due to the heart related damages
or the stress and the global
cardiac by market size is expected to
reach about
the u.s dollar 26.33 billion
by 2027 and you know it's
exhibiting a compound annual growth rate
of 11.2 percent
during that forecast period it is uh
being provided
by the uh the news report by the
business
via dot com london and um
because of the reasons regarding
biomarkers uh the market is expected to
you know witness a significant growth in
the near future
and uh if you see uh
in addition to the to the technological
innovations
and because of this increasingly older
population
and rise into the cardiac diseases and
there's also we are needing more of
improvement to the healthcare
infrastructure
and it it also you know these are the
combined significant
growth drivers for this high rising
market of the cardiac biomarkers uh
well when we are talking about the
emergency services because
our talk is going to more concentrating
toward the
uh the emergency services of
cardiovascular diseases
so we have the two cardinal biomarkers
which are the
evidence-based guideline endos
and also the white lie uh widely you
know the clinically
applied markers the first is the cardiac
troponins
which are now you know the essential
essential requirement for the diagnosis
of the
myocardial infarction and also you know
the govern the
immediate management studies with
respect to the need for
the early invasive intervention
whereas when we are talking about the
nature take peptides
they have partially filled you know the
formally unmet needs
to improve the diagnostic certainly
and to provide the early risk
stratification in case of
uh the acute heart failure thus
uh questions are uh you know what
remains to be done
and what is the present and the future
needs
so here we see the importantly that
we need to know that uh when we're
talking about the current biomarkers
and laboratory as the stakeholders so
where the large stands
so you see approximately the two percent
of the patients with the acute mi
have the diagnosis missed into the
emergency department
and uh more in large they are the few
very specific reasons has been
identified for the same
firstly uh the inappropriate discharge
of the acute mi patients
which has been found you know the core
problem in
uh is admission of patients with the low
probability of the
acute coronary syndrome where
we may miss cases requiring the urgent
help
and uh you know the patients those who
have some
some atypical symptoms like in you know
in case of
the the coronary uh the artery plaque
rupture
or we we call as the acute coronary
syndrome
the next is uh the decisions onto the
testing protocols
which are often made without the input
from the laboratory people
or without input from the laboratory
medicine
it means that the bottles should work
with the emergency physicians
and with the primary care physicians
with a cardiologist
and the hospital administration
and energies at the chest pain centers
the rapid ami rule lord protocol are
very essential for the earlier my cases
which are you know powered by the ecg
testing
uh the timely blood collection for the
measurement of the cardiac biomarkers
and respectively the
more measures the lastly
the important uh the significant
the factor is the qualitations where the
role of the the
regulatory compliances comes and
it is the important aspect of the
regulatory compliance as well
for example at the registry router
link to the next
so when when um when we talking about
the cardiac
marker so what is a new into this system
right now
so in the rule out acute micro
infarction process
the cardiac troponins is the sole
recommended biomarker
and using the 99 percentile cut point
and with the two labels drawn at the
time
between the 0 0 three hours
and uh zero and three to six hours
specifically and when comparing the us
hospitals to the guidelines only
uh it is surprising to know but only the
twenty four percent use the cardiac
dropping in only strategy
whereas the 49 percent use the 99
percentile cut point means the two lab
results
at the two points at the two different
time zones
and the 35 percent ruled out the my
current function
within six hours so you can you know you
can understand these strategies
are also being differently drawn at the
different places
so it is not consistent with the
recommended guidelines which are leading
to an
increased cost with the longer acute mi
uh rule out times without the clinical
benefit to the patient
so um when we are talking about the
monitoring and the measurement
of the of of
these units or the role of the lab
personnel
so it is very important because you know
the selection of devices
whether the education training being
required to how to use this biomarker
the timeline the turnaround time etc
whether it is verification whether it is
compliance so everything is very much
related to
the expertise of the lab personnel only
one of the important point is also being
discussed is the reimbursement
for the testing protocol for example if
you see
the center for the medicare and the
medicaid services
has announced that it is not necessary
to use the
troponin in addition to the creatine
kinase
which includes the the mb
enzyme that is the ckmb
while in the management of patients with
the mi that is my contractions
suggesting that the reimbursement will
not be allowed to
uh from the from the companies
when both tests are being ordered it
means that the private insurance
companies may also ignore the limit the
reimbursements
for the correct biomarkers so it means
that the guidelines should be very
specific
and should be drawn by everybody for the
benefit of the health care and for the
benefit of patients
so going to the next before
we go ahead uh being uh
going into the ai that is the artificial
religions of the cardiac biomarkers
let's have a look more into the
laboratory
[Music]
precisely the laboratory setup of the
correct biomarkers
precisely again into the emergency
settings although
the time of chest pain onset
for the ami patients sometimes is uh
is known this information is less
available or you can say it is less
reliable for those who are
you know coming with unstable in china
india there are many patients with
acute coronary syndromes who experience
silent ischemia
and infection that means there's no uh
pain during the exclusive episode so
that's
uh is it really that repeat kind in my
marker testing
is leading to the earlier detection and
use of the appropriate therapies is it
really true
let's have a look at it
so when we are talking time that means
we are uh you know focusing towards the
utilization and the ordering
it is a complicated phenomena because
laboratories
uh need to you know consistently
delivering the ninety percent
of the of the current wire marker that
results
should reach to the patient area within
30 minutes that means
it is a it is a very high amount of
expectations
while maintaining the turnaround time
whereas the results of cardiac marker
testing is
are not used to guide the thrombolytic
therapy
in practical means and as stated earlier
there is no
clear evidence that the availability of
rapid biomarker
just leads to the better patient outcome
so so yes which
this concept does not support the need
of a very rapid turn on time
or any single sample so
it means that we we are you know going
towards the
99th positive theory that means we have
to
take the samples and the two time zones
uh
one at the zero to three hours and then
at the six hours
now the next important part uh to
consider in case of pre
analytical aspect is the sample type
so uh of course when we are
uh you know talking of plasma for the
measurement of cardiac myomarkus
and that really eliminates the extra
time which is you know necessary for the
clotting process when we are requiring
the serum
therefore it also reduces the overall
turnaround time for the cardiac
by market testing so uh
it is very important that this type of
sample
we are using and which type of testing
we want in that
sample type the next is uh
the the the interference by the leukemia
the ectrace or the hemolysis so
however the several cardiac troponin
acids are influenced
by the hemolysis and the magnitude of
interferences related to the cardiac
troponin and the free
hemoglobin concentrations excess of
lipids or proteins
can also prevent the proper aspiration
thus leading to the inadequate sample
volume
the next is the sample stability
however uh disabled studies have been
documented
that the cardiac troponin concentrations
are relatively unaffected during the
short term span of storage that means at
the four degree celsius
or minus 20 or minus 70 when uh
being properly separated from blood
cells and stored properly
however the the long term stability is
less understood and being less studied
and where the more planning may be
required in that case
lastly the important is the delta check
[Music]
the diagnosis of ami necessitates
observing a rise
and or fall into the into the cardiac
propellant concentrations
that means that we want to mark a change
whether the disease is progressing
towards the
worsening or it's getting better with
the treatment
which requires at least the two cardio
properly measurements in most
clinical scenarios and for the
contemporary assets the testing
intervals of at least the three to six
hours
have been shown in effective effective
at increasing
diagnostic accuracy
the the then the important the third
point
important is uh defining the clinically
relevant threshold values is again
complicated
and international guidelines for the
diagnostic
acute micro infection endorse the
implementing of the 99 percentile
of the healthy population as a upper
reference limit
but it do not define the specific
strategies
or it does not specifically define that
how to rules
uh it did not specific define the rules
which can be you know
used for detecting that significant
delta
the fourth important point while we are
checking delta that means the difference
of
the two values uh is that
the the studies of or the studies of
both the cardiac troponin and the
the cardiac troponin eye acids being
poorly harmonized
and as such it is complex to translate
the clinical
or analytical data between the assays
now going to next the analytical part
again repeat turn turnaround time which
remains in the four
most important area of uh uh
to have they have the uh
the lab results that will lead to the
expedite
uh patient discharge and also reduction
into the complications so uh
again when we are talking about the
cardiac emergency we
need to define as the uh sd
segment elevation mi or as non
st segment elevation mi however
the results from the serum cardiac mye
markers are not needed in making the
acute treatment decisions
into these stemi patients
and when we are talking about the the
point of
care testing uh of course now
the various instruments are being
available which are you know
doing a wide white level
and white range of the test menu
and also can do the myoglobin uh the
ckmb
the cardiac troponin t cardiotropin eye
and many are available into the
multi-market formats as well
these assets make the use of the
anticoagulant
whole plant and can have the analyzer
times of about say about 20 minutes
that's
you know it is having a long impact into
the length of stay operation as
it can reduce the length of stay it can
also reduce the lap cost because of the
rapid availability of the testing
results
and reporting of the cardiac biomarkers
as well as you know
uh important ones the important markers
the
nature take peptides going to next
when we are talking about the
anticoagulant variability
so uh it means that uh the
what are the interferences which can you
know interfere
with the the testing of that particular
current my marker as first concern of uh
the the cardiac troponin immunoassays
there are the uh anti-cardiac troponin
antibodies has been identified which are
known as the heterophile antibodies
that can lead to both the false positive
and the false
negative results but in practice
false positive results are more
frequently reported
overall the prevalence has to be
estimated to be 0.1 to
three person
the well exact mechanism of you know
that remains elusive of uh these
heterophilic
parties but uh they bind to the region
antibodies in a manner that links
the solid phase and the detection
antibodies
thus enabling them to form a sandwich
a kind of um in a complex together
and gives the appearance of the
quantifiable analyte
thus you know it is uh interfering
with the results and overall the
prevalence has been estimated to be
point one to the
three percent into uh the cardiac
troponin assets
now uh the next is the
instrument function where we can say the
flyers
or the cardiac tropon results that are
initially significant
unsignificantly decreased cardiac drop
in concentration
which again
the declogging the the equipment
is having a you know the
artistic component as well
the troponin harmonization which has
been
it has been coming to uh
the next that is the post analytical
we need
the images of the cardiovascular
diseases
are they
we need the quantitative interpretation
for sure
you know we need to identify the optical
medical
point positive or negative values
so it can also you know help in
strengthening the
risk stratification
for diagnostic threshold
the it is defined as the 99 percentile
of a healthy reference population
as a diagnostic threshold to identify
the micro
injury and to aid
[Music]
association of clinical
criteria first the high situation
listen to impose sensitivity methods
should measure the cardiac troponin
concentration
above
and the method that it should be
available into
the 50 percent of the hindi subjects
have enrolled into the large populations
thus you know detecting that the delta
change
is very important where we are you know
trying to find out the
change into the values of the cardiac
properties
over the time uh in spite
of a single absolute concentration
one more important uh uh
is also you know uh
i want to share yes it is
reporting in what we perceive
what our eyes see to it
so for instance so the 209
[Music]
and 0.2 nanogram per ml
are identically uh
unit choice makes the result seem high
whereas the second
signal so it's also very important that
what is the unit we are receiving you
know to
report the correct prior markers
next is important is how the evolving
cardiac cardiac biomarkers are with
technology
um so the source of new biomarkers has
been you know identified as six major
excess
like in case of inflammation in case of
oxidative stress
in case of neural heart motivation
inner dysfunction and the kind of
cardiomyocyte entry
and the
electricity
to the picture important to improve the
risk
stratification and scientific
uh for management of the
healthy patients and the settings and
is helping into the early diagnosis and
to rule out at the traging of which
is found inside
also important is you know the disc
monitoring settings
as for example the
cardigan if you take peptides and
cut it drop of an option
uh also uh as per the technological
advancement
uh it will also enable the extensive
screening
of macros in any given cardiovascular
disease patients
thus you know uh that system biology
approaches
towards the omics it's becoming more and
more
widely acceptable for the
research area that includes the
proteomics
metabolics and exploration of
circulating
nucleic acids including the micro rna
and it also inputs the the non
coding rnas that are screened on
extensive nucleic acid chip arrows
now uh coming to the important
area that is the
artificial intelligence or we
call as neural network so artificial
intelligence
by large describes a range of techniques
that allows the computers to perform
require the human reasoning and problem
solving skills
using either the predetermined tools and
search
algorithms of pattern which are you know
recognizing the machine learning models
thus a process large amount of data and
recognizing patterns into the data
as it was also called as the internet of
things
um again a neural network is
is a common type of machine learning
which is inspired by the way
as the animal brain was as you can see
into the picture there
are several dots which are
interconnected with each other into the
multi-layer
network so it is a multi-layer network
of interconnected units
like uh like the neurons that process
the information by you know responding
to the external
inputs thus you know will rely to the
information which is you know flowing
between the
different neurons from one to another
and as you can see
into this model for example uh example
of
uh you know one cancer cell has been
taken
that how it uh you know being
differentiated
between the healthy or the cancer cells
including the
input of the different uh different
factors like the morphology the height
of cell the stiffness the thickness
and these information you know
correlating each other
as a blue dots with the inter deep
layers
giving the output as a yellow dot
or the kids research
now the evolving biomarkers are uh
are also happening with the advancement
of the technology
and the ai has led to the significant
paradigm shift
into medical knowledge and omeg data
uh of course the in case the input data
is quite
varied which is you know ranging from
the social
environmental to the clinical laboratory
or to the ohmic data
and ei is having a positive impact
including the ideology pathology whether
the
or importantly the cardiology also for
example if you see you know the
congestive heart failure
and unless that that was reflecting
about the 10 percent of the senior
citizens
and the estimated cost was about the 35
billion each year
35 billion use dollar each each year
into the united states
ai tools are helpful because they have
you know helpful in predicting the
advanced
potential challenges ahead and allocate
the resources to the
to the patient education and also to the
sensing and
to the proactive interventions
and machine learning uh is also part of
the
the ai and being
being used as a terminology
against the ki only
now here are the few few papers as you
can see
okay so here are the few papers as you
can see in my screen that
uh in patients uh those are presenting
to the emergency department
the machine learning techniques using
the patient data whether
including the a risk factors the
chemical markers the genetic markers
could improve the diagnosis
and then also there to try it
as you can see in a paper by
okay right so as you can see into the
paper by
sha it all they have evaluated the data
science and approaches to
reduce the misdiagnosis and enhancing
the
triage procedures of the non-stemi
for the non-cardiogenic chest pain
and they have built the artificial
neural network they
showed an area under the receiver
operating characteristics with the
accuracy of about
uh the 98.4 to the 98.6
force introspectively which is quite a
huge
uh success i must say and in other paper
by the martin at all uh the machine
e-learning
algorithm incorporating the a
type collection with repaired
sensitivity called troponin eye
concentrations
was trained onto the about uh uh
three three thousand patients
and tested onto the about us eight
thousand patients with suspected
myocardial infarctions
and in another study
another study by the wing at all as you
can see it showed that the
medical and the ai that is the machine
learning can improve the cardiovascular
disc prediction
by correlating the complex interactions
between the risk factors
and the researchers by this study have
provided
data on to the about 295
about the 100
000 patients to four
medical learning algorithms for the
training purposes and
they have tried correlating the medical
history with the the heart attack rates
and uh they have found these
algorithms you know performing very well
and been
correlated even better for the diagnosis
with the when they have compared with
the american college of the cardiology
and they have showed the one about the
two percent fear
alarms into these studies
so it means that by all
means that laboratory is quite
important in case
of a patient care thus the fundamental
importance
the fundamental importance is to ensure
that the patient is given the high
quality care
by adding the value to the lab test
thus the the test should be clinically
valid
which can provide the highly accurate
diagnostic information
it should be clinically effective that
means it contribute
improve the patient care and the patient
outcome
uh test results should be cost effective
so
you know you can provide to the reduced
health care cost
and in all that if you see the
inter-professional collaboration
is very much needed where the clinical
decision making
uh should also uh take
the help of the laboratory services
that's the contribution laboratory
services to services to the
clinical decision making not
only depends on to the performance of
the body itself
but also on to the behavior of the
clinicians with regard to
you know requesting the test and and
seeing the trends
and using the results and these
interpersonal in inter professional
collaboration highlighted the factors
that shape you know
the the interface including the
responsibility accountability
coordination whether it is
communication and many more uh the
factors which are important you know
uh to develop the mutual trust
and respect between the the clinicians
andy and the laboratory of
the hospital services
so uh in today's era
the needs of clinician if you see as per
the studies it has been identified
that uh now the the needs of the
clinician
from the clinical laboratory is more
toward the diagnosis
so that they can help into the treatment
selection
as compared to the monitoring or as
compared to this feeling
uh but it should not be like you know
you know giving uh
a test menu to the patient and asking
what you want to
so that means we need more of robust
mechanism
for diagnosis of the patient
patient patient disease so we can help
into the
better outcome
so there are the few opportunities for
the improvement
has also been seen for example you know
improving the adoption and adherence to
the
evidence-based laboratory medicine the
few
uh uh the much of the work
has been started into the various
countries like the uk nice
the national institute for the health
and care excellence pathway
that offers the interactive online
clinical algorithms
that is linked to the detailed evidence
based information from diagnosis
to the treatment options similarly the
computerized physician
order entry that is cpoe and also the
not plus the norwegian
quality improvement for the laboratory
services in
primary care
that means the clinical audit are also
very important
part of the current testing
system in fact so uh
so that we can you know have a more
evaluation of the requesting patterns
and the test related outcomes we can
also you know coupled with the
individually tailored presentation of
findings to reduce the inappropriate
requesting patterns
now um as a part of the medical college
uh another part of the of
the healthcare system so i'm trying to
you know concentrate
that what is being uh taught to our
medical
students into about the liberty medicine
into the current
situation what are the future doctors
learning today about the laboratory
testing are they really
going well about the laboratory testing
i
is such an important part of healthcare
system
so you see in that case as per my
experience the limited knowledge of
clinicians
about how the liberty functions and how
to interpretate
test results may have verizon because
you know the pathology being taught into
the medical schools is
predominantly in arctic pathology
more less of a chemical pathology
and so uh so because
we have uh limited teaching of
liberty medicine into the medical
schools
we uh we really talk about the
tessellations
we really talk about the result
interpretation we have a limited
instruction
in the training courses on test
selection and laboratory setup
so uh to pass if you say uh the most
medical students must know
what a heart looks like under the
microscope
after heart attack you know that they
should be identified but not what the
blood tests are needed to diagnose a
heart rate
but but i'm sure that we all know that
um
no one does a hard biopsy to diagnose a
heart attack
so that means the integration of the
free
para and the clinical subjects is an
important area
that we cannot be forgotten so uh
to to have the
uh to to you know to
conclude this particular important
lack of medical education the medical
council of
india have emphasized from 2019
to the new curriculum for the
undergraduate medical teaching and they
have
introduced the early clinical exposure
and
what is this ece that is the teaching
of the learning methodology which
fosters the exposure of the medical
students to the patients
as early as the first year of the
medical college that that means
uh you you may bring your students
to the real health settings
real clinics where you can you know they
can
they may be helping as an observer
from the classroom setting to the
hospital setting
or may also to the community setting and
one can also you know use the cases to
teach in the class with the help of the
the paper case or maybe the photographs
the extras like what it is
ecg and so on
yes um of course not only the doctors
but the uh the training of a direct
medical staff
education and the continuous training is
also very
important so i have uh shown the slides
in my other picture from the latest
and the recent the the cme that we have
conducted
into our department in 2019 though
everything has been stopped after the
the kobet
pandemic in 2020
yes ai is beautiful but it also has some
challenges to address
importantly to drive the reliability of
making clinical decisions protection of
patient data with respect to privacy
whether uh having an impact onto the
doctor-patient relationship
the accuracy uh the medical legal
integral
uh ethical implications for the
practitioners
its utility to the clinical practice and
its utility in respect of
the the claimed outcome the lack of
data because yes uh the ai has done a
lot into the many
places like into our grocery settings
into
the many more areas but yes into the
healthcare settings it is
still having the limited span
so that a few guidelines have been given
like for example by the
fta us where the policy for the device
software function and mobile medical
application guidance
was first issued in 2030 and further
updated in
15 and 2019 as well
so to conclude
so to conclude in addition to you know
redefining the building upon
studies to enhance diagnosis and
prognosis of
upcoming ai focus into the cardiology
that should include the development of
ai driven algorithms to aid the clinical
decision making
in test appropriateness
test selection scheduling workflow
prioritization
protocol patient management
these developments will not replace the
role of physicians
in other healthcare professionals
but it will definitely going to improve
them with the highly accurate tools
to detect disease stratify
risk in more consistent manner and
optimizing the patient-specific
management
so there's a need for the growing
cooperation and to provide the guidance
on the test selections and for the
interpretation
of the analytical results